Elon Musk wants Twitter but he doesn't
got it yet time for what to watch we've
got Jill here our money expert to talk
about it and Vlad you're going to run us
through the top of the of the
introduction to this whole conversation
he doesn't have it yet until I say he
has it
I'm always kidding I'm only kidding Elon
uh yeah we are going to talk Elon online
two for you left
what to watch what I'm buying that too
so we got four I'm billionaire Elon Musk
bombshell offer to buy 100 of Twitter
this morning's announcement came just
days after he bought more than nine
percent of the social media platform and
then back out of an offer to join
Twitter's board of directors must says
Twitter this is a quote now Twitter
needs to be transformed as a private
company so yes we've got Jill here to
break this all down I find this
absolutely fascinating that he rejected
the offer uh to join the board and then
decided in this filing with the SEC that
he wanted to buy the company outright to
take it private right he doesn't want to
be I think Guided by SEC rules now
remember remember when you're a publicly
traded company the SEC has a series of
rules about board directors the number
of shares and percentage of shares you
own the disclosures you have to make and
you have what's called a fiduciary
responsibility to your shareholders
you've got to do what's right for the
shareholders first before anyone else
and it takes it private if he takes it
private he doesn't have that he's a
responsibility to who himself he could
do whatever whatever
exactly and so I think this is a really
interesting moment of a hostile takeover
of a company to bring it private so he
has control over it so who who decides
whether this hostile takeover is
successful will he actually take control
of the company well I mean the
shareholders so here's what's really
fascinating because they don't have to
sell it they don't know
the shareholders and and they have to be
the ones they're dangling a lot of money
in there absolutely and you only have to
get a certain percentage of those
shareholders to say yes before doing it
so a few numbers for you guys um if you
look back I looked at Twitter's IPO
price back in 2013 was 26 bucks a share
it went up to 45 after the first day of
trading it has had a bumpy ride in fact
if you look at Twitter say compared to
Facebook Facebook stocks have has
crushed it and what is he offering now
and he is now offering 54 a share now
listen there are some folks that I just
spoke to very quickly on my ride into
work who said 54 is too low the stock
just traded at 70 a couple of uh you
know within the last 12 months so there
are shareholders who could hold out for
more but remember this is a very a
compelling offer to just get out of a
stock that has been underperforming did
say that his offer is 54 it's a 54
premium over the share price before he
started buying the shares and a 38
premium over the day he made it public
can I just say one thing about that
though because he didn't disclose it he
was able to buy shares before if you
knew Elon Musk was buying you'd be like
let me sit back and see what happens but
people who sold it to him say
um a few weeks ago and they didn't know
they were selling to Elon Musk they
missed the first 38 percent rise in the
stock and now they may say oh I want
that money back you're a Twitter user
and you're sitting here today what does
this mean to you if he buys it do you
have a pros and cons I think what he has
said is he wants to make this a
subscription-based model that is
fascinating to me that he would what's
the I don't get it if you're all about
Free Speech yeah and the Public's saying
what it needs to say why would you take
it private make it subscription based
because I think he wants to make money
and I think there are a lot of analysts
who look at this company and say it
hasn't made as much money as its
potential because you need an ad base
but also this man in the world why are
you saying he needs to make money uh
because he wants to do something more
than that well I think he also wants to
influence the conversation we were
talking before we came on the air this
is a product Twitter that is not so much
a money maker but it does influence
media government politics you're in the
conversation under the current
configuration does Donald Trump come
back if Elon Musk is I think that
there's a possibility that that gets
reversed I really do it's a it's a tug
and pull between making money and Free
Speech right either you're all about you
want to make it this platform for free
speech or you're saying to yourself I
want to make it about but you could have
two you could have two different levels
you could have an ad supported one and
you could also have one that is a
subscription base and it's going to be
interesting to see this story is not
over yet it's the beginning the filing
is the beginning of the battle but
remember this free speech would be as
Elon musk's sees yeah
on Twitter check it out just listen to
thank you very much